let's look at the next category best
argument
what i mean we've probably had about 50
arguments just in this episode
like the most heated argument or like
the most memorable i wonder what what
the viewers of choosing basically yeah
right
because if it's like strictly speaking
the most argument argument it's got to
be the gatcha thing right
oh yeah that was by far the biggest guy
i think we had that was
probably actually an argument yeah but
i'll
just let's look at the nominees for this
oh yeah we've got your gambling game
unless you [ __ ] gathered a thousand
bucks and haven't got the one with thick
thighs
you forget about three months later [ __ ]
that's true
it's true it is true and then we got the
hamburger
again we've gone over this one uh the
crosstalk no cross we've obviously gone
into play this clown clown
uh and then bidet or no i forgot about
this one could play the crushed one
sometimes it just
crumbles apart without the crust it's
like the integrity of this
sandwich has been ruined it's been
optimized
you cut off all the useless pieces
although
[Laughter]
although and this is where it started
moments before a disaster the bidet clip
not realizing day or november i don't
want a wet [ __ ] ass
you don't have to be wipe that's what
toilet paper was invented
then i don't want wet [ __ ] fingers
after i wipe that's just
how [ __ ] weird are you are you wiping
with your ass you [ __ ] grumbling
i still revisit this to this day because
she's so funny
i just can't believe this man doesn't
utilize the bidet just the lack of logic
in this argument
okay i mean the thing the thing about
the bidets is i still
stand by heated toilet seats but today
i'm still just like
if if the toilet paper i got here wasn't
so [ __ ] thin and break so easily
then i would use the bidet more often
but it's it's the wiping afterwards that
gets me mad it's the wiping afterwards
is a clown gone why didn't were you
always this much of a clown i'm sorry
who won biggest clown corner
i'm sorry here you go justly so i can't
say anything
i would like to believe that that is
more clown [ __ ] we have an una reverse
card ready at all times what do you
think's going to win this one boys oh
god
i mean any of these could honestly win
uh [ __ ] man
i've i mean i have no idea this is one
of the most iconic things in trash taste
which is our argument and i feel like
i feel like the gacha one is just such
an intense argument yeah yeah
it's got to be the most memorable surely
even out of those until
if you think i mean it's
it's literally the great burger debate
yeah not an argument
you know what i mean like the gadget
wanted something [ __ ] argument i i
would say the great burger debate was
like
more heated quote unquote um the crust
one was pretty heated as well
yeah um the gacha one i don't know like
i
you guys should watch the bidet one
because that got [ __ ] heated
i think you did this one again yeah i
can't remember exactly it got pretty
[ __ ] heated i showed you the gatcha
one the etch one sticks in my head so
much i don't know why yeah honestly like
i mean i look at all these and out of
all them the gacha one sticks out is the
one where i'm just like
yeah i i don't really like agree with
what i said on that one yeah
i'll i'll back pedal yeah everyone had
some pretty [ __ ] takes on that one but i
guess that's what made it interesting
but yeah again there can only be one
winner sagan
oh it's me is it on you
never mind all right here we go best
argument for trashcase award-winner is
gotcha's gambling ah okay
that you know what makes sense i think
it was by far the one that made the
viewers be like are they okay
yeah they're gonna be okay after this
argument watching a friendship
that wasn't the case there was you know
all the other ones they know
you funny but that was the one where we
got so many comments people like oh god
yeah okay you know we were okay don't
worry
we are still friends we're all great
because i commented be like guys guys
seriously it's chill yeah
don't worry it's like it's fine we were
just in it we're getting so worried
because we were really going at it yeah
what was the percentages on that uh
gambling one with 36.2 percent 36.2
percent
in second place was the state debate
with twenty four point four percent
okay oh no cross came in third with
twenty day one was worth
the day one it's because i feel like
they came last because not many
not enough people have the experience
yeah to have an absolute true true truth
i personally advocate for the bidet clip
though it's so funny it is a good place